- Рот, губи. Дуже добре. А де живіт?
Тема уроку - лексика для відвідин лікаря.
Рахіб разом з іншими біженцями відвідує
мовні курси при одній із віденських церков.
Два роки тому вона з дітьми втекла із Сирії.
Радіє, що її малеча вдома
дедалі частіше розмовляє німецькою.
Будь ласка, подай мені тарілку. Подай мені сумку.
Постійно заучує це з дІтьми.
Рахіб - одна з найкращих на курсах для початківців,
не пропускає жодного заняття. Але навіть такій старанній учениці, як вона,
незабаром доведеться ще більше зубрити німецьку,
аби отримувати соціальну допомогу в Австрії.
Усі відвідувачі курсу - шукачі притулку,
які сподіваються отримати дозвіл на проживання в Австрії.
А це означає - й право на мінімальну соціальу допомогу
в розмірі близько 860 євро.
Утім, правоконсервативний уряд Австрії на чолі із Себастіаном Курцом хоче,
щоб цю допомогу в повному обсязі отримували лише ті,
хто зможе посвідчити добрі знання німецької.
Решті допомогу скоротять на 300 євро.
Уряд Австрії скорочує фінансування мовних курсів для шукачів притулку.
З іншого боку - вимагає, щоб люди, які подають клопотання
клопотання про притулок, тобто які хочуть отримати правовий захист в Австрії,
і, відповідно, мінімальну грошову допомогу -
щоб вони мали високий мовний рівень.
Одне суперечить іншому.
Те, що права біженців ставляться в залежність від мовних знань,
багато хто вважає вкрай проблематичним з правозахисної точки зору.
Не можна самому обирати, складати цей іспит чи ні.
Людина нічого від цього не отримує.
Навпаки, втрачає щось, а саме: право на соціальну допомогу, на забезпечення існування,
що, власне, має бути гарантовано всім громадянам в Австрії.
В альпійській країні дме новий вітер.
Мігрантам створюють такі умови, аби вони почувались тут некомфортно.
У Відні половина тих, хто отримує мінімальну соціальну допомогу, - іноземці.
Для австрійського уряду це занадто.
Він хоче завадити - цитата - "міграції в австрійську соціальну систему".
У наступні шість місяців усі погляди будуть спрямовані на Австрію.
Відень буде розставляти в європейській політиці вирішальні акценти.
Насамперед у питанні біженців.
Жорстку політику Австрії можуть взяти за приклад й інші країни ЄС.
На запити DW партія Курца не відреагувала.
Зате відповіли в Європарламенті. Депутатка від Зелених Моніка Фана
вважає, що політика уряду Курца загрожує соціальному миру в Європі.
Це, цілком очевидно, пропозиції, які на руку європейським правим
і на шкоду соціальній Європі.
Себастіан Курц та його уряд свідомо йдуть на це.
Це антиєвропейський уряд.
Рахіб та її співкурсники не зневірюються.
Мовні курси для них оплачує мерія Відня.
Їхні шанси скласти непростий іспит з інмецької не такі вже й погані.